If you can look,
I'm surrounded by books made out of paper and
the atmosphere in the room is 20% oxygen.
So have you ever wondered why the paper
doesn't spontaneously stop burning
that matter? Why doesn't I have stopped burning or even me?
And the answer is a really important concept in chemistry called
activation energy.
You probably know that when something burns, it gives that heat,
the molecules start at a higher energy than they end up afterwards.
So the difference between these two Heights is the energy
releases. In order to release that energy,
you have to put in a bit of energy first to get the reaction going.
And that energy is called activation energy.
It's a bit like having to buy a lottery ticket before you can win a lump
sum of money.
But the difference is if you put in activation energy,
you definitely will get the energy out.
Whereas if you buy a lottery ticket, you may not win.
The reason why in the case of oxygen
that you have the activation energy or part of the reason is
because oxygen has unpaired electrons.
You can see our video that shows that oxygen is magnetic.
And if I take the liquid oxygen, you can say,
I can pull it right up here and you have to pair these electrons up
to get the reaction going. Now,
once you've got a little bit of the reaction going,
he took your paper with a match.
Then the heat that is given out will make the reaction
self-sustaining and it will in fact go faster and faster.
And you can put the activation energy in different ways,
either by heating things, you can do it with mechanical energy.
You can hit the chemical mixture with a hammer.
For example, when firing a gun,
the hammer hits the cartridge and sets it off.
Or if you strike a match,
the friction on the side of the matchbox
produces enough heat to get the reaction started.
You can also put in the energy with light.
And there is a very famous.
Reaction where you react hydrogen and chlorine
and set it off with a flash of light,
Right breaks,
the bonds between the two chlorine atoms and the
cl two molecules.
And those CLL Latins react with the hydrogen produce
heat, which then makes the reaction go off.
So once you've started it just like lighting with the match,
it goes to completion in that case with a really quite
spectacular bang.
When you have any collection of molecules,
some of the molecules have more energy than others,
and a very tiny number have a lot of energy.
So when you put in heat,
you increase the number of molecules that have a really lot of energy,
and then they have enough energy to react.
So quite a small amount of heat
can have a surprising effect on the rate of the reaction.
Why does it need that heat for the reactions to happen in the first place?
Like why, why wasn't it already right.
Reacting?
Because there were not enough molecules that had the energy to
make the reaction to go fast enough for you to realize these
books are reacting with oxygen.
But so slowly that even though some of them are more than a
hundred years old, essentially,
very few of them have reacted.
Some of those books are on fire. They're just on fire. Very, very, very, very,
very, very gently.
They oxidizing very slowly. I suppose.
Quite a good example is if you eat a chili baby,
or sometimes I think in American,
they call gummy bears. If you eat one of those,
you eventually convert it to carbon dioxide and water,
but flames don't come out of your mouth.
But if you rate them high temperature like Simon,
Neil did on one of our videos.
Oh wow, that's it.
You get huge flames because the reaction is going very fast.
And we should be able to fit not one, not two but four jelly babies,
a chorus of jelly babies into this one.
[inaudible].
This brings us on to catalysts.
And the major role of a catalyst is to reduce
the activation energy so that you don't have to put so
much energy in to make the reaction go.
And very often these catalysts can be metals.
For example, platinum,
and the platinum will absorb molecules on the
surface and for possibly make the
bonds between the atoms break on the surface,
and then they can start reacting.
And when Brady and I went to the platinum refinery,
we saw large sheets of woven platinum wire that
were used for the reaction between oxygen and ammonia to make nitric
acid. And you can see it's got really quite a nice herringbone pattern,
rather nicely than my suits. You would make a nice suit.
And these big sheets of platinum could be used on an
industrial scale to lower the activation energy for this reaction.
The whole point of a catalyst is that it can take
parts in the reaction, but it ends up in the same state it started.
So it can catalyze the next molecule reacting.
You mentioned before that platinum was forming an actual break of bonds.
Is the platinum involved in that chemical reaction or is it just its presence
making those bonds break?
Well,
if you think about it in the bulk of the
platinum metal, the,
you can imagine the platinum atoms bonded together.
And those on the surface don't have
neighbors because they're at the edge. So they have,
if you'd like dangling bonds, which the oxygen can bind onto.
So there is a transient reaction, a short live reaction,
but at the end,
the oxygen leaves leaving a space for the next oxygen atom to come
in or oxygen molecules come in.
Are there reactions where the activation energy is so high,
that the reaction only happens while you're pouring in activation energy?
And once you remove the activation energy, it can't be self-sustaining.
Well, this applies to what is called endothermic reactions.
These are reactions,
which rather than releasing energy require energy,
the energy of the product.
So it's higher than the energy of the starting material. And in that case,
you have to keep on pouring in energy to make the reaction go.
Most reactions tend to be exothermic.
Exothermic reactions, where the it's so close to zero,
it's only just tipped over into exothermic that you have to keep pouring in
energy. Anyway, yes, their reactions.
That go from very endothermic to very exothermic.
And there are quite a few that don't give out very much energy at all.
The reactions of manual Ganek compounds are not very
exothermic. They have, um, an activation energy,
which means that around room temperature,
if you increase the temperature by 10 degrees Celsius,
the rate of the reaction, approximately doubles.
So if you heat it up by 30 degrees,
the reaction will go eight times as fast it's as if you like the
fact that organic compounds do not have very exothermic
reactions. Except of course,
if they burn that allows you to build up very complicated,
organic molecules,
inorganic molecules tend to have much more exothermic
reactions.
So they release their energy and one great foot and they've
exploded or burns or whatever. Do you prefer exothermic or thermic?
Well, if you want to do a good demonstration,
that makes our YouTube viewers say, wow,
there's nothing to be too good. Exothermic reaction.
[Inaudible].